good morning everybody i'm michael naft
i represent this area
district a on the clark county
commission i'm pleased to be joined
by superintendent jarrah peggy wilson
is the principal here at cartwright from
zero fatalities andrew bennett
we're proud to be uh partnering with our
wonderful ccsd police
and i thank the chief for being here
along with metro who is always here for
us in in full force
i also want to thank trustee guzman
whose district we're in here in district
a
uh and most importantly i want to thank
all of you because without you this
message would not get through to our
parents to our
students who in this unusual time are
are heading back to school and as you
all know on monday and just a few days
from now
students will be heading back to school
elementary school
they're our smallest students they're
our youngest they're the ones we really
need to make sure know the rules of the
road the rules of the sidewalk how to
ride their bike and be safe on our
streets sidewalks and
getting to and from school we also want
to make sure as they ride the bus that
they're safe doing that
and that the drivers understand that
it's been over a year
since we've had students on our roads on
our sidewalks
so this is really going to be really
going to require
some change in behaviors and attitudes
and really an
understanding for those in our community
who don't have students going back to
school on monday
and might not be in that mindset we want
to make sure that all of them fully
understand the responsibility
that we share in this process it's going
to require some some changing of habits
as i mentioned
and to our drivers we want to remind
them of the rules
always drive attentively obey all school
zone traffic control
including reduced zone speeds uh
when approaching school zones and
crosswalks reduce your speed and be
prepared to stop
stop for pedestrians and bicyclists and
wait for them to cross completely
never pass a car that is stopped at a
crosswalk
and obey the three-foot rule which is
three feet from a bicyclist
that's a law here in the state of nevada
and never ever drive distracted or
impaired
and as you can see with our force here
our friends and law enforcement will be
out there to make sure that you don't
but we also know that the responsibility
is not just that of our drivers but that
of our pedestrians and the youngest ones
as i mentioned
to them we ask that you plan your route
stay visible
wear light and bright colors stay alert
put your phone down don't wear your
headphones
walk on sidewalks if no sidewalks are
available
ensure that there is safe distance
between yourself and passing vehicles
and walk facing traffic only cross when
it is absolutely safe to do so
and make eye contact with a driver don't
assume that they see you
uh out as you're walking in front of
their car
we're not here today because of this is
some exercise or some date on the
calendar or some hypothetical situation
it was just a few years ago in 2008 that
a student of cartwright elementary
school
a nine-year-old boy was killed while
simply trying to leave school
he's been remembered as an energetic cub
scout who loved being outdoors
the driver was not impaired she wasn't
speeding she stopped at a stop sign and
looked left before turning right
hitting the boy in the process this
is an example of something that can
happen to any one of us in our community
and it's an all too painful reminder
that what we're asking for here today
has real life consequences
i'm begging our community please slow
down
please pay attention and together we can
make the return to school a safe one for
all of our students for our parents and
for all of the families
who are already dealing with so much i'm
pleased as i mentioned to be joined by
superintendent jara
who i'll turn the podium over to now
thank you very much
thank you thank you commissioner and
again thank you for being here this is
important um as you heard commissioner
nath um welcoming our most precious
asset
in this community our children back to
school is important so i
i i applaud the county for calling this
event
and really sharing some of the facts and
the need
for our community to slow down as we
start
to bring our children back to school on
a face-to-face
hybrid model as as has been noted
multiple times and discussed march 1
monday morning
with great anticipation and excitement
that our kids are returning to school
our educators are excited
in our schools and our classrooms as we
continue and move into a face-to-face
instruction for
all our children april 6th we'll
continue we'll have
all elementary school students
practicing social distancing and our
high schools
and middle school students will start
march 22nd
let me give you some facts so we're all
aware what's going on
in addition to our walking routes
and on our sidewalk we will be operating
1600 bus routes
across the valley carrying all students
we ask you to watch out
not only as our walkers are coming back
but to watch and follow our bus routes
and
our really are
our rules of operations when our when
our buses
are stopping and picking up our our
students
our police officers along with our
partners in metro
and all throughout the valley again
thank you for making sure that our kids
are safe
let me tell you a little bit about some
of the procedures that are also
important for the families to have a
clear understanding and the training
that our bus drivers
have gone through in our process to
cleaning our schools
and our buses students are required to
wear their face mask
at all times use hand sanitizers when
they're getting on
and off the bus the buses will be
equipped with self-dispensing sanitizer
bottles
and spare face masks in the event the
studer a student requires
a replacement face covering drivers will
load the bus
from the back to the front and unload
from the front to the back
each student will sit in the next
available seat and follow
seat markings to ensure that our kids
are practicing social distancing while
on the buses
students mo only report to the bus stop
on their assigned cohort
if you recall cohort a cohort b
between school bus routes bus drivers
and aides will use
disinfecting wipes and handrail door
frames and
on tops of the seats a thorough
disinfection process
will also take place each night to make
sure that
all the interior bus coverings are
disinfected again if you want to learn
more
about the procedures that we're taking
on our buses
reconnect ccsd.net has all the outlines
in there
now as we move forward i'd like
to introduce and welcome zero fatalities
program manager
andrew bennett who is here working with
all law enforcement including
our ccsd police
good morning my name is andrew bennett
a-n-d-r-e-w-b-e-n-n-e-t-t
i have the privilege of representing the
nevada office of traffic safety which is
a division
of the nevada department of public
safety and to manage our state's traffic
safety education awareness program
zero fatalities i want to start by
thanking commissioner naft and dr
jarrah for working with us on this vital
important public safety concern which is
making sure that our most vulnerable
road users
are safe when they return to school on
monday and throughout the rest of the
school year
there's a sense of urgency in our voices
when we talk about the importance of
pedestrian safety
as the last time that we had instruction
learning in the schools
which was august 2019 through march of
2020
we had 41 school children hit on their
way to or from school
one of those resulted in a fatality and
three of those were left serious injury
injur seriously injured which resulted
in life-changing injuries
and so when we talk about the importance
of pedestrian safety
literally lives are on the line and that
is the reason that we are here to talk
today about pedestrian safety
and school zone safety the mission of
the nevada office of traffic safety is
to eliminate serious injuries and
fatalities
so everyone arrives home safely and it's
that idea of everyone that idea of
perfection why our goal in the state of
nevada has and always will be
zero fatalities each year we declare
that our goal for the school year
is zero fatalities for school-aged
children and we fully intend to meet
that goal this year
as we have a abbreviated in-person
learning opportunity
and how we plan on achieving that is
through education and enforcement
this is the greatest opportunity that we
have through education so i appreciate
for everybody of the media being here
and we want to talk about two different
sets of laws number one
what is considered a school zone and
number two some of the common laws that
we want you to follow in that school
zone number one
for school zones when is a school zone
active there's three different ways to
know
if children are present if the lights
are on or 30 minutes before after school
those are all indicators that it is an
active school zone
the laws that we need you to make sure
that we're following as we approach
uh monday and throughout the rest of the
school year
commissioner nafta mentioned these
number one no u-turns in an active
school zone
number two no passing another vehicle in
a school zone
so what that means real quick is if the
speed limit is 15 miles an hour in that
school zone
and someone's going 10 or 11 miles an
hour the new speed limit is basically
going to be 10 or 11 miles an hour
you're not allowed to pass
another vehicle in an active school zone
and finally
speed speed kills we have extremely low
speed limits in the school zones and
that's for designed
to eliminate that possibility of a
fatality to happening
so we need to make sure that the public
is participating in those
slower school zones our office has a
program
called joining forces we partner with
over 27 different law enforcement
agencies
across our great state and we're using
that opportunity through a pedestrian
safety enforcement period
which is a maximum enforcement period
right now we're coordinating with all
the southern nevada law enforcement
agencies
including clark county school district
police las vegas metro north las vegas
highway patrol
henderson police department boulder city
to make sure that we have those
additional resources through overtime
funding
in our school zones as we approach the
return to school
on monday one of the things that we
cannot enforce
in school zones is kindness compassion
and understanding
usually we go through the school year or
we finish the school year we have all
summer
to get ready for a school zone with
school zones comes an increase in
traffic
increase in delays and a longer commute
but kindness and compassion is what
we're asking for
in addition to following the laws and
finally as a proud product of the clark
county education system here
there's a few names that will always
stick with me as i go
throughout my life miss uh miss yani
miss peebles miss heavy
um mr perry mr greene miss shumway miss
chanos miss
conklin those are the names of my
elementary school teachers when i went
to school here
we deserve it for them all their
children and all of us to make sure that
we're able to get them into the school
safely and transverse our school zone
safely
and so that concludes our press
conference we are all three available
for individual
uh press for interviews at this time so
feel free to grab us but we are not
going to take questions at this time
thank you so much